it is definitely very windy out there
still we've got those gusty winds
we had near 60 mile an hour winds in the
mountains overnight
wind advisory did expire at 5 a.m they
did turn the power off
to the folks up there at mount
charleston to avoid any power lines
being pulled down by the wind and
starting fires
we've got a lot of 60s around the valley
this is just so unusually cool
but enjoy it because we're going to pay
for it next week when the
heat comes back with a vengeance 55 up
there kyle canyon
all these beautiful 60s around the
valley but we still have winds
gusting to about 25 30 miles an hour in
the valley
most recent gust at mount charleston was
35 so these winds are still pretty bumpy
out there
high today 89 we were 94 yesterday so a
pretty
good drop again today this is going to
be our coolest because the numbers start
going
right back up tomorrow 97 is the average
today's record 108.
most records though for june are at 110
and above and that's where we're going
to be next week
this weekend triple digits return as
soon as saturday
and then look at these high temperatures
next week between 110
and 115. you know officially 117
is the hottest temperature we've ever
recorded we get
temps hotter than that in certain
neighborhoods but 117 is the all-time
high we've ever recorded in las vegas
we're going to be real close next week
all right out at the lake sunny skies
but breezy to gusty winds
by the way the lake water level is at a
thousand
seventy one and a half feet right now
that lake is
oh so low that ring just keeps getting
bigger
89 degrees for the high today again is
going to be
so cool compared to the rest of the
eight day forecast tomorrow we're right
back to upper 90s
104 on saturday 107 on sunday
and then we're sweating it big time next
week at 109
to 1 15. we've got wednesday thursday
both
15 with our morning lows in the upper
80s so everybody stay cool heat watches
have already been
reissued for next week